Ross what are some of the best tips for
writing a webseries well I think the
first demand in web series is to be
economical in your storytelling and to
make sure that you're telling that each
word that you write in your script does
something to advance the story to
entertain to clarify who the characters
are to deepen the characters and to you
know use it you've got such a limited
amount of time you should use every
second you have for entertaining what do
you advise to your students in terms of
looking at other webseries do you have
them go on YouTube or or Vimeo and
things like that and absolutely and I
try to screen for them in class both
examples of things that I think are very
good and examples that I think are not
very good and to talk about you know
where someone might have gone wrong in
my opinion including showing previous
student work I had a student several
years ago who had what I thought was a
terrific idea for a web series it was
called model family and it was narrated
by a 15 year old boy who said I don't
feel right in my fan I don't fit with my
family because I grew up in a model
family I don't mean everybody's perfect
I mean everybody's a model and then you
meet his family and his father's the
brawny paper towel kind of model guy his
mother's an underwear model and his
brothers a like an Abercrombie shirtless
jean model and they're in those
characters as if they come off the pages
of a magazine as real human beings in
the house - and I thought it was a very
clever concept for a web series and then
they went to cast it and they had
trouble I teach at Chapman University at
the dodge College of film and media arts
and we're in Orange County so sometimes
it's hard to get actors to come from LA
and they had a casting session and said
well we really didn't get anybody good
so the student cast himself as the
father and it completely ruined the show
you didn't believe it was a real family
you have to believe for that premise
that as bizarre as the family is that it
has some sense of reality to it right
and that's what I'm curious about is
what is it that makes an audience sort
of glob on to the series and the
characters versus not and I'm sure it's
not a sign
yeah it isn't science it's an art there
but you know the characters I think are
the main thing that when they are kind
of this paradox of both fresh and
relatable now you when you if I've named
any television show for you if I said
it's a classic television shows Happy
Days first thing that's going to come to
your mind is the Fonz I would bet or if
I said all the family the first thing
that's going to come to your mind is
Archie Bunker - today if you say
something with Modern Family the first
thing is going to come to someone's mind
is whichever of those characters are
their favorite characters and that's
what brings you back episode after
episode to a series there you relate to
the characters it's why I think Felicia
day's show the guild had such a long
life there because she had a it was
about getting online gamers and she had
an audience of people who were online
gamers themselves so they could relate
to those characters so going back to
model family tree if it had been redone
and these were more even if they weren't
likeable characters but she just there
was something in them that was more
human what do you think it was I think
was casting it in and the direction in
that particular series there but yeah I
think the concept was a good concept
there but when you take a 22 year old
guy even a guy with a beard and say hi
I'm the dad it doesn't seem like a
family - it seems like students
play-acting at that point in time it's
why you know I revised whether they're
my students or they're people out in the
world we're making web series that you
need to find real actors to be the
actors I know we'd all like to pretend
that we can act but we all can't act and
so it's really worth the effort to go to
a theater department somewhere go to a
local theater find actors who can bring
something professionalism to your
project
you